I'm going to talk a little bit about the
improved standalone blast databases in
particular I'm going to emphasize the
ability to get taxonomic information
from them directly so we're gonna learn
about the new versions of blast the
blast databases we're going to see how
to limit your search by taxonomy using
the information that's built in those
databases I'll so also show that you can
search sequences by accession faster
using accession lists or CID lists and
we'll use a program that's part of the
blast package to retrieve sequences by
taxonomy from blast database which is a
handy future okay so the main motivation
for us in making the version five blast
databases or one of the important ones
is as you probably know NCBI is
preparing for a future where we don't
have GI numbers or sequences and so
blast needs to be able to deal with that
and so that's part of the motivation for
making these databases they have some
other features though that are more
useful right away from people these have
much faster lookup of accessions and
other string identifiers and that's part
of getting ready for the GLS proteins
but it also includes map taxonomy
identifiers for all sequences in the
database and that's the main thing we're
going to be taking advantage of today
these are available as a alpha release
on our FTP site there's a link to the
directory that contains the executables
for 2.8 0.0 plus those executables are
required if you're going to work with
the version 5 databases and there are
some examples of those available also on
the FTP site if you want to try this out
so just to set the stage for what we're
going to talk about today one of the
most important things you can do when
you search a blast database is to limit
to the smallest database that contains
the sequences of interest the most
common way people do that in the most
biologically sort of a useful way to do
that is to limit to a taxonomic group
that you're interested in and so as you
probably know on the web pages you can
enter taxonomy queries organism limits
we might want to call them you can you
know you can select certain organisms
for example in this case I've got green
plants like that and then I could remove
a subset of that for example I could get
rid of the monocots they're all the
opposites and so that would give me a
smaller blast database and make it
easier for me to understand
interpret my results if you want to try
to implement this on standalone
traditionally this is managed by the GI
lists and as we know those are going
away there are some other problems with
creating GI lists one of the things that
we often recommend to people although in
some cases it's just not doable and
that's to download a GI list from entre
and for example you could do a search
for bacteria and you could get all the
bacterial proteins this way in principle
the that's a lot of proteins and in fact
it's so many proteins that even these GI
lists are difficult to download so we're
going to show you that with the built in
taxonomy information that sort of gets
around this problem it makes it a lot
easier to deal with so if you look at
the standalone programs the restriction
options are available for the search
programs and also for some of these are
available for Blas TB CMD as well one of
them that's we're going to demonstrate
for you is that seek ID list restriction
works a lot better than it did in the
previous versions of last use this could
be a list of accessions you need to
convert them to the version 5 format
using plasti b alias tool and i'll show
you how to do that you can also have a
negative sneak out a list that's
everything but the ones in that list and
then we have all these various ones that
work with taxonomy identifiers these are
the taxonomic identifiers is the integer
ids from ncbi taxonomy database so you
can specify a list of them on the
command line or ones you want to leave
out negative tax IDs or you can also
make a file a tax ID list or a negative
tax ID list and blast DB CMD also lets
to retrieve sequences from the databases
using the taxonomy IDs so how do you get
the taxonomy IDs well on the web you
could do that and these are much simpler
sets of identifiers are much much fewer
identifiers is if you take a taxonomic
group downloading these is easier than
downloading GI lists so for example if I
want to get all the green plant GIS I
would use this query green plants and
then in brackets sub tree which gives me
all the identifiers is that our can
within that particular taxon I could
download this as a tax ID list I can use
complicated queries if I want boolean so
I could get Greenblatt's without the
monocots in them but that's one of the
options in them and then they can just
download this as a file on my hard drive
where I have blast installed and I could
use that to limit now if you have blast
installed by the way that's about two
hundred thousand IDs for your green
plants if you have last installed
typically you're going to have it
installed on a UNIX or unix-like system
although people do run this on Windows
the following options I'm going to tell
you about do not work on Windows because
it uses a shell script but there is an
included shell script with the new blast
alpha release it's just a shell script
that invokes the NCBI redirect package
to get the taxonomy IDs it basically
runs that query that I just showed you
on the web we're gonna get all the tax
IDs and it really it's a very simple
script you give it a name like I could
put green plants in there or I give it a
tax ID that I could get by first
searching with the name to find out what
the tax ID is and when they do input a
tax ID it gives me all the tax IDs that
are contained within that group so it
explodes that whole thing and those
eventually get you to the point where
the sequences are mapped and you can get
all those sequences for your blast
searches or to retrieve them from the
database as I said this option is only
gonna be available for Unix Linux more
cygwin partly because it's a shell
script and partly because it relies on
eat erect so this is going to require
that you also installed a direct package
and the instructions are on that link
there basically there's just a little
script there that will if you paste that
into your window you'll install you
direct for you it only uses these search
actually but you need to install what
the package so for example just that
little script if I put the word soybean
in there as an argument to end it will
give me back a little output that tells
me what the tax ID is what the rank is
etc and so forth and the scientific name
if I want to get a list of tax IDs I
first need to get the parent so I could
say green plants
and then I would pass that tax ID for
that larger group back into get species
tax IDs and it would give me back a list
of the tax IDs that are in that and of
course I could just redirect that output
to a file and that would be my tax ID
list argument the name of that file now
the other thing that with the string
lookups making things faster it does
allow for faster searches using
accession lists and these are just some
data that Tom Madden and others here
have compiled looking at comparisons for
how fast things are with the new
databases and in particular you'll
notice that with the accession list a
new database is as fast or faster than
searching with the G ILS which was not
the case before one of the things about
this if you get a list of exceptions you
need to convert them into a binary
format and there's a utility that comes
with the blast distribution called blast
DB alias tool basically it will turn
this into a version 5 seek ID list which
is binary and sorted I guess so here's
just some sample command lines these are
real simple command lines that we're
gonna in a few minutes look at some more
complex ones that make that optimize the
search a little bit more for using the
various kinds of things we talked we're
going to talk about today so for example
the first one here so here's a this is a
simple blastp search i'm going to use
this Argonaut protein from the fission
yeast as a query for everything we're
going to do today and then here I can
limit to the tax ID 38 47 which is
soybean so I would only be searching
soybean sequences the second one I could
look at all green class if I have that
tax ID list I could do a blast search
against an R that contains everything
except green plants if I use the
negative tax ID list then say I want to
get all the FAFSA proteins for soybean I
could use blast DBC MD to do that this
time directly with the tax ID which is a
very useful thing to be able to do and
then this would just give me that in
facet format then finally if I have one
of these seek ID lists like this one
where I have
all the human non-model refseq proteins
which is one we'll use in a demo in a
few minutes you know I can do that
search and restrict to a particular set
of sequences so let's do a few things on
the command line here and see if we can
get them to work in real time while
we're watching them so I'm going to get
the tax IDs for soybeans and flowering
plants and I may reduce that the size of
that to soybean to a bean to the P
family just to make things a little bit
easier and I can limit the last piece
search to soybean or to flowering plants
once I get their taxonomy IDs then I can
use blast DBC indeed to extract the pea
family sequences from in our database by
the tax ID you list then finally we'll
do a search limiting in R to the human
gnaw model refseqs by the seek ID list
I'm gonna load the terminal up here and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to go
back and forth between the terminal and
a text document here that and also a web
browser so it's going to be a few things
shifting around just so we can
demonstrate a few things so the first
thing let's do what's let's do those
same kinds of queries that we talked
about before on the web so I'm just
going to do a web browser for this
particular thing so let's just say that
I want to know about what's the tax ID
for soybean I could just come to our
taxonomy database and run this on the
web and if I retrieve that record I've
got the tax ID right here 38:57
so that's a simple one that's that's a
what we might call a leaf node or a
terminal node tax ID and there's going
to be sequences in the blast database
that are mapped directly to that tax ID
the other thing that I might want to do
is say I want to do flowering plants
just do that when it's an example so in
this case I want to know not just a tax
ID for flowering plants but I want to
know the tax ID of everything that can
its contained within that and so when I
do that I get a hundred and seventy
thousand taxonomy IDs
if I wanted to make attacks that he list
out of this I could simply save this to
a file by checking that file box here
which means a format tax ID list and
that tax ID list would be ready to use
and blast let's now go to the command
line to do the same thing with those
tools that we talked about a minute ago
so I have this thing installed in here
so let's go ahead and get it up so there
it is this is a shell script that's in
my directory here and I can just type
help to see what the options are this is
a very simple thing so basically I can
give it a name or I can give it a
taxonomy ID so let's for example give it
a name just to show you how that works
and once the typing gets awkward I'm
going to go ahead and copy paste these
things in here so that's a quick way to
get the tax ID there and if I want to
get flowering plant tax IDs I could do
that as well or if I want to just get
the P family I can do that too let's try
that one okay so that would be I would
know where the P family is then I can
get that as a as a tax ID list if I want
to so let me go ahead and go over here
and I'm going to start using my scripts
here okay so let's go ahead and we'll go
ahead and run this one which we're going
to get all the P tax IDs that's going to
take a few seconds to run you can see
there's just a list of tax IDs there
that I could now use to limit a blast
search okay so what I want to do now is
let's go ahead and use the first
instance of the tax IDs which is just
simply to use a tax ID on the command
line and I'm going to put this in
and before I run that let me just
explain a couple of other options that
are here because they're useful to know
about and give you some additional
options here so one of them is blastp
fast which is just uses a larger word
size plus some other things to make the
circle run a little quicker I'm using a
thread this is a multi processor machine
I've got an e value restriction here and
then I'm modified output format seven so
that for example one of the things a lot
of people want to do is to put the
sequence title in there so that's going
to be there I'm also going to get the
scientific name of the organism in the
output format here is 7 which is tab
delimited let's just make this an output
file just so we don't have to watch it
scroll across the screen we'll see how
long this takes actually I should have
named that soy bean tab but that's okay
so there is my dad delimited output and
I've restricted simply to soy bean so
this is using the organelle protein from
Sky's of Sakura my C's palm be the
fission yeast and these are all the
corresponding protein blast hits from
soy bean okay let's do the second
instance where we're going to use a tax
ID list to limit to a larger set we're
gonna limit to the P family and I could
do this to flowering plants green plants
whatever I want to this will replace our
peas tab with the real peas tab and now
the only change in the command line is
that instead of using the tax ID arguing
I'm using the tax ID List argument here
let's see how long that one takes
okay that wasn't too bad and now we've
got other members of the P family the
fabaceae these are other beans or being
relatives but not to soybean so we have
more of them now so we can scroll
through that if we want to and it has
all the features that I asked for in my
tab delimited output so I have the title
of the sequence subject sequence plus
the scientific name for example well
let's say I want to get sequences out of
the blast database this is a pretty
handy thing to be able to do so for
example suppose I want to get the
soybeans sequences from NR and where I
get around a blast search now we're
going to actually try to get those
sequences and dump them out so the real
simple option would be to get all the
soybean sequences so this is a blast DB
CMD command line and it uses the tax IDs
argument to give me just those sequences
from soybean and I'm going to dump it
out and fast a format that wouldn't take
so long to do it's going through all
through in R and getting out the soybean
sequences and so they have to dump out
of the soybean sequences from in our
likewise you could do the same thing
with all the P family which I won't
bother to demonstrate but that's there
the command line is there in the handout
if you want to take a look and try it by
the way all this stuff is in is on the
FTP site with the rest of the directory
so you can you can try that out yourself
now one thing that you might want to do
is to make a list of Nahuatl refseqs now
what I did was I change the example I
was going to do peas but I decided just
to make it simple and fast we're going
to just do two human and this is a way
of subsetting the database with an
accession list and I'll put this one in
here
now you may notice that this has nothing
to do with blasts this is just a way of
running the search in each search I'll
go ahead and run that and I'll come back
over here and bring it back up again so
you can take a look at what that is so
this is a way of running an e search and
course e directors is installed that's
otherwise I wouldn't be able to use a
shell script here this is a query that
would give me a nice list of proteins
for human these are the ones that are
refseqs but they're not modeled so
they're not the XP types of refseq some
people don't want to see those for human
there's not that many of those for some
organisms there's lots of those and then
I'm just going to get them back from
protein database in the accession format
so I get a list of accessions
and that's running right now and that's
not a tremendously large set where they
go for about two more seconds if it
doesn't stop I already have it have this
saved okay so let's just head that so we
can see what's in there so that's just
going to be a list of these NP style
accession numbers now in order to use
this in blast to limit the database
search what I have to do is I have to
convert it to format that the class
program can read so I'm going to take
the blast EP alias tool and I'm going to
do that conversion and that's going to
make it into this see kotti list and
that doesn't take long at all and so now
the last thing that I'm going to
demonstrate is to run the search
limiting to those human non-model
reference sequences again it's a blast
peak command line exactly like the ones
we've used before the only difference
here is that we have the seek idealist
argument which we did not have before
okay so let's take a look at that and so
this is a small set of results these are
just the nominal refseqs that match that
protein from the fission yeast and so
that's a nice blast output there okay
you go back to the PowerPoint slides so
basically what we did today was we
talked about the blast db5 version and
two-point 8.0 plus works faster with
string lookups it's a much easier
options for taxonomic filtering the
blast databases and it works faster with
the accession lists so there's no need
for using the GI lists any longer the
last slide here has its links to lots of
useful material about a direct blast and
so on and so forth remember if you have
general questions about NCBI you might
want to check out our inside NCBI
insights blog you can check out our
learn page and our FAQ sheets and our
YouTube channel if you have specific
questions please feel free to write to
me peter cooper at nih gov you can also
write to our help desk get info at NCBI
NLM the nih gov or a blast help that's
the same domain name so i'll throw it
open think there have been a lot of
questions so so far there are three
pretty good questions that i think
everybody might like to hear the answer
on we may not have all the answers so
again there will be a Q&A document that
we will get all those in the know to
answer and post those on the web the
first one is this happens to be an alpha
release someone knows noticed and wanted
to know when the final version might
actually be released I don't think we
know that I think the idea is that we're
gonna leave it up there for awhile and
how long that's going to be may depend
on how much feedback we get the point is
we're trying to get people to try it out
and and tell us what they find so I
encourage you to do that and let us know
what you think and let us know what we
can do to make it work better for you
second question will the blast API be
extended to support these new features
yeah so I I think that's what I was
going to say too I
no I guess the right way to say this is
we have no plans to do that right now if
there's interest in doing that let us
know and we'll add that full list of
things that we need to do the last
question I currently have is so if we're
currently downloading the NR database
from the FTP do we have to format it
with texana me info or is it already
format and ready to go right so a couple
things there is the one that's on the
FTP directory that I pointed you to
there's a different one than the normal
one the one that's up there any ordinary
Blas directory where you've always
downloaded the database that's a version
4 and that taxonomy information is not
in that database there is no way that I
know of for you to add it to that
database right right so that's what I
was saying the one on the version 5-1
the link that I sent you those have
taxonomy but the version 4 ones do not
so right now there's no way for you to
make those into version 5 ok well that's
it for today then and if there's any
additional questions I'll get them
written up thanks everybody for coming
and we'll talk to you next time
you